here in this video we are going to rank
the most evil ghidorah incarnations ever
we are going to take a few things into
consideration regarding the ranking
and that is the origins of the specific
incarnation the reason for the
destructions and deaths it has caused
and also if it was acting on its own
free accords or just controlled by
aliens and maybe its natural tendency as
a creature to act on his own instincts
so maybe you have your own list so do
put it down in the comments section
after you watch this one anyway
subscribe if you haven't and now let's
get down to business
starting from the bottom we have king
kidaro from gmk and he is the least evil
of all the ones in this list
in fact he is unique in a way as he is
the good guy a guardian monster of japan
kingidoro was one of the three guardian
monsters and in ancient times he was
known as yamata no orochi
now we come to ghidorah from the heisei
period this version of ghidorah is by
far the least evil other than the
benevolent guardian monster from gmk
initially being three adorable
genetically engineered creatures called
dorads that were like little puppies
they became ghidorah after being exposed
to the radiation of the nuclear testing
in the pacific
i would say that this version is morally
ambiguous and in fact was just a pawn
used by the forgerians to destroy japan
but was defeated by godzilla it was then
later transformed into mecca king
ghidorah and was sent from the future
into the past in order to help humanity
fight against godzilla so yeah the hazy
guitar wasn't evil at all more or less
just a hapless spawn
next we have monsta x geyser ghidorah
let's see about this incarnation well
monsta x was summoned by the zillion
aliens from the gorath asteroid which
has unknown origins and unlike most of
the zillions other mind control monsters
monster x displays true malice fighting
viciously and relentlessly he seems to
take pleasure in causing godzilla pain
monster x's maliciousness and
aggressiveness is further demonstrated
when he continues to battle even after
dragon and the zillions are defeated in
and any other mind control the aliens
had over him severed but he was still
brought to earth involuntarily and that
is why he isn't the most evil incarnate
next we have dez ghidorah yet another
space monster daz guitar is an ancient
alien creature and a relative of king
ghidorah that gains power from
destroying and feeding off the life
energies of the planets it attacks
it arrives in the solar system
approximately 65 million years ago and
cleansed mars of life before moving on
to earth but was beaten back by mothra
but after destroying the civilization of
the ancient alias people his subsequent
awakening in modern times caused a lot
of destruction and even caused the death
of mothra but then he was defeated by
the offspring of mothra called monstro
leo given his nature and greed for life
force he wasn't really evil but just a
creature that needs to always feed so
let's put him in the middle of the list
next void ghidorah a monstrous entity
that takes the form of a three headed
dragon a golden one and inhabits the
void between dimensions ghidorah has
always used supergravity to consume
countless worlds throughout the ages
a hundred thousand years ago guidora
destroyed the planet ex of callus the
homeworld of the eggs of aliens but just
as does ghidorah this incarnate was also
indifferent maybe most specifically a
malevolent force of nature going on to
consume worlds as it was as it was as
nature to do so we couldn't
lie in evil for eating a gazelle so the
same would be for death guitar and void
ghidorah they are just going on about
instinctually destroying stuff
next shower ghidorah from his origins as
a malevolent space monster king ghidorah
had once attacked the planet venus under
his own power thousands of years ago
eradicating the planet's entire
civilization in only three days in 1964
king ghidorah arrived on earth inside a
meteorite eventually emerging from it
and attacking the planet cities even
leveling them to the ground but was
defeated by mothra godzilla and rodan
and sent back into space in the next
encounter this guitar would be under the
mind control of the zillions and later
the kailax as well as the m space hunter
nebula aliens so even though this his
initial appearance shows him as being
quite evil his later 2 makes him just a
pawn in the schematics of alien species
now we come to the monsterverse
incarnation
this guitarist non-terrestrial biology
shows that he was an extraterrestrial
life-form who acts as an invasive
species to earth's biosphere it is
unknown however where guidor exactly
came from following its rampage across
earth and its defeat by godzilla in 2019
its consciousness would live on and its
influence would then override apec
cybernetics ultimate destroyer mecha
godzilla during the events of godzilla
vs gong and in each movie in each time
he appears it was seen that this monster
loves causing death and destruction and
even killing humans which can't really
hurt him and this puts him high on the
list of being very malicious and one of
the most evil incarnations of ghidorah
and the number one spot goes to grand
king ghidorah coming from the rebirth of
mothra well the origins to this monster
is a bit tricky a bit different grand
king ghidorah's younger form cretaceous
king ghidorah first arrived and attacked
earth 130 million years ago and then
went on to quickly cause the kt
extinction event uh well he exterminated
the dinosaurs and almost every other
life form on the planet he then engaged
himself within a meteor and left the
earth and using the life essence of the
creatures he had destroyed to live as he
traveled through space
130 million years later cretaceous king
ghidorah arose again as grand king
ghidorah and came to japan to feed on
humans mainly children but he soon
started to eat adults as well and while
doing this it shows that he was sadistic
and likes to cause death
well this puts him on the top of the
list of the most evil incarnate of
ghidorah
and so with that we come to the end of
the video of the most evil versions of
king ghidorah do tell us what you think
and put down your own thoughts in the
comments section below anyway this is it
till the next time take care fam